there is a sperm extract or the Chinese
company made that goes for about six
thousand dollars and it's meant to mimic
a vagina so it pulsates in the same way
it has the same the same level of
brightness and wetness and more well
sign me up but six grands a lot of money
because it for six grand I can get the
top-of-the-line real vagina mm-hmm
they said they actually send this out
all over the world for places where men
can donate sperm so then women for like
infertility issues and so you can
actually find this at a lot of different
places where you want to have a family
like a real glory hole it really really
is it's really a real glory hole would
be a mountain state a mat wealth just a
hole I know but here's the thing human
behind there who can have some real
daddy issues disgusting yeah I called a
true I got this machine thing so I can
bust this machine thing it's just like
then they take the sample mmm oh that's
sick
yeah this is way better than jerking off
into a web [ __ ] yeah but also I just
bust into this tube it's real glory hole
I got a question I just busted that tomb
then they take care of it yeah I got a
question how many other guys have busted
in that tube well yeah clean that thing
you know you gotta clean it now who's
the clean let me ask something
who's the cleaner let's say it's a
woman's mouth how many do the bus in
that mouth who cares don't care right
you kids you like you so hey would you
buy a used Ferrari of course I would do
it is but if a woman had however if a
woman was uh uh-huh and then I yeah your
turn I'd be like [ __ ] this in a bun
around the mouth its yeah there's some
rigid you there's some residue in that
that that's a Cinnabon that's been used
a lot I'd have to be not afeard me well
yeah I mean if you're close to your boy
I mean you know solo it in first oh man
good yeah and then came out you're like
alright well I know what she's been I'd
still have to be like that's yeah yeah
Tichenor just remember like good like
that's good
drag-out CB o--'s yeah that that that's
fine but that's a that could have been
that tube could have had 400 dicks in it
since last Tuesday yeah dude but if
you're not a professional she sucked a
thousand dicks and you get Jonah how
many is leaner than a human now because
the human mouth roll there's a decision
contain STDs though true but also do
they they'll have to does it have to
look like a kids [ __ ] player yeah
yeah it can we make it a little more
sexual yeah they were actually making
this for men who are too timid to do it
manually too timid yeah yeah this is um
so you're this company's based out of
China and apparently there are a lot of
men who would go to these clinics and
they weren't comfortable jerking off oh
wow bunch of puss and [ __ ] [ __ ] this
tube wait hold on do I have to do I just
sit there and get sucked off by this
tube or do you really let me see that
I'm gonna thrust into it look at it
oh dude I'll definitely stick my dick in
there there's a bunch your buddies just
get sucked off Rose come on the box
ahh it looks kind of nice and it's warm
in there mm-hmm bad thing is do your
things I mean it can make you a little
cooler looking but whatever it's a
hands-free device oh wow look at that
thing we take a sea anenome
yeah it does man bound of light it's a
mechanical [ __ ] I don't want a lot of
light that does look pretty dude I
definitely it's like it's nice in there
of our genes yeah it's so interesting
four million views so I guess just you
you just stand by each other - that's
gonna be weird I guess you could watch
some porno like you've you if you it's
almost like peloton friggin sucked off
maybe out that there you a screen on
demand just pick the type of girl you
want and you just there's a [ __ ] and
this just virtual her suckin yeah and
you getting sucked off by the robot dude
how about you how about the fact that
yeah I know with all those people
doesn't have enough young people to
support its growing economy and work for
how about that whoever thought saw that
coming the company sells 10,000 machines
every year yeah 13k dude we should get
one for the studio then I guess come he
gets sucked off that's that would buy
robot you know as a little as well thank
you thank you thanks to the show man
make sure you see the robe on the way
out who's gonna play it who's gonna
clean it you need a pressure hose don't
do that no no I asked a bunch of girls
that question what would you rather do
drink horse urine a horse semen ah semen
all day girl said semen yeah guys like
urine I I would have to it have to be
urine from it would be neither for me
Miami like okay I know is that was in
fact oh yeah fear factor yeah definitely
piss meet you wow you do that machines
pretty [ __ ] cool though I'm not
whatever hump down down for that
oh do you do that porn dude it's a great
idea do if you had one those in your
house I bet dudes won't cheat on their
wives so much yourself when your closet
like be right down again sucked off by
robot who does she care be right down
it's a great idea dude it's fast
fascinating well the guys weren't
[ __ ] sailor Hilda Lake so that their
hair does not get it the weather let us
look at this run take you as hats the
bills are a block up the Sun yeah why do
you have pillows factory right do you
not 13 grand a big you do you know a lot
of Miss Piggy you use my breath 7 G's a
lot of [ __ ] machines huh I'm not I'm not
gonna lie dog get one what's it called
the Sun way does the only come with that
anime that's a little [ __ ] I have right
now yes don't be nice to you pick a some
well it's probably I don't have porn you
know it's the internet go to pornhub
maybe your son demand like peloton and
maybe a real live stuff you're watching
the most peloton
anyway go on Jim what else you got when
you see my back I pull myself up like a
champ 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
yes